un jour les trains être de légende
le dévoilement de la bande annonce du
film donne est un grand moment pour les
fans du livre culte mais aussi pour son
réalisateur denis villeneuve
j'ai peu soir la course l'avenir je peux
le voir ces premières images sont
spectaculaires
denis villeneuve dévoile sa vision de la
planète de sable harakis rempli des
pistes de longvic est peuplé par des
bergers en crise aura été très inspiré
par l'écologie dans la biologie par les
écosystèmes par le vivent à quelques
jeunes soient plus mal il ne s'était
passé
la peur tu l'esprit respectueux du livre
original
denis villeneuve a repris des phrases
clés de l'oeuvre de fac un but ce qui
réjouit sylvain st pierre qui a lu tous
les romans du cycle originale ses
promoteurs définitivement ses promoteurs
le les toutes les images qu'on a vu faut
réellement partie de l'histoire telle
qu'elle apparaît dans le lit un animal
pris au piège dévoreur à sa propre patte
pour s'échapper le monde de 12 est
difficile à adapter au cinéma le
réalisateur david lynch s'était
d'ailleurs cassé les dents en 1984 son
avec son 12 que plusieurs considèrent
comme une abomination
mais fort de ses films de
science-fiction l'arrivée eh ben les
douanes 2049 denis villeneuve pourrait
se rendre là où nul homme d'état les
avants qui s'y passe quelque chose en
moi j'ai très hâte
je ne suis pas le plus grand fan de
denis villeneuve pour plein de raisons
mais je crois que chacun de ses films
est un événement maintenant et qui a
justement une capacité de créer à
l'intérieur d'un système qui est le
système hollywoodien tout en gardant
justement une liberté que d'autres
cinéastes ont tort
il ya mis de son côté toutes sortes de
collaborateurs qui nous permettent de
croire au film doté d'un budget de plus
de 150 millions de dollars américains le
12 versions denis villeneuve sera un
film sans compromis la concession le
film donne doit prendre l'affiché le 18
décembre
ici louis philippe ouimet radio-canada
moria